Kevin Van Horn if there was one thing
that I would say about video games in
2014 or indeed any year preceding that
is that we just don't get enough zambese
just not enough no zambese indeed that
won't be a problem in early 2015 when
this game comes out from the makers of
other such zombie survivor games as Dead
Island this is tech lands dying like
dying light finally putting zombies in
the spotlight where they belong with
some Mirror's Edge sprinkled in for
goodness well who can't deny the need
for little mirrors I just sprinkled here
and do a bit of Mirror's Edge there oh
you already okay here we go I want to
drop drop some hot parkour rings off by
doing that sweet there we go go
so the idea of course is that this is I
mean I hate to be reductive hmm but the
idea that is somewhat like oh it's Dead
Island in an open world and with parkour
in a pretty open world and it is a
pretty open world I really like the way
the game looks actually I love like I
love sites like that and the neat thing
is you end up getting two I presume
go to some of these places probably not
all of them you're playing these some of
them you're playing on PC right I am
playing on PC and we should mention as
well you're actually about five hours
into this game but this is where we're
playing now is right after the tutorial
yes we're ideally i've played like five
hours but then this is a new install a
new PC so I just played through the the
tutorial stuff so I could get into the
open world and show people what's going
on cool right now so I play a dude named
crane crane yes and I've been sent here
to kind of involve myself with this
place's factions to find out it's a
little mysterious right now I'm not
exactly sure what's going on so crane
has the voice of Booker DeWitt great
does that mean it's Troy Baker it is
Troy big wonderful let's see every video
game that came out already last year and
there we've got one in 2015 and so
what's what what's the premise in terms
of like story has the zombie apocalypse
happened like five years already or
something no it's not done much yet to
actually show me okay
like the history of the zombies right
now it's more
it's it's more concentrating on what's
going on right now at this moment and
I've been bitten oh and as it happens
where's the zambra ends up being a big
problem well exactly although here it's
called antigen mm so we're gonna start
running out of zombie antidotes pretty
soon if I keep doing this so the idea
here is that I need to go to the doctor
hit that zombie I keep the zombie oops
why do I keep jumping it's because I'm
used to having this this move that I
can't really cool off oh yes you have a
drop kick or so I have a drop kick but
because so there you go we should I
guess mentioned that one of the things
that Techland have been sort of talking
about in terms of features for this game
is that during the day the zombies are
kind of like stupid dolts and then in
the nighttime is when they turn into
crazy ravenous like 28 days later so
yeah that's that's totally true luckily
you're not really doing stuff at night
for quite a while until they until they
decide how come everyone in the zombie
apocalypse lost their right arm it's you
don't know anything about zombie
apocalypses do you so this reminds me
I've been watching on Syfy and you watch
anytime fine I don't hear you know I
like myself alright so I would recommend
helix okay yeah so this reminds me of
helix this game is full of this kind of
[ __ ] medicine where people are
always where it's just like Star Trek
the technobabble type stuff only with
medicine right and there's there's all
sorts of that helix is kind of like that
so you like that kind of BS zombie
medicine we need to split the genome so
we can find this yes it's the z
chromosome yes so I I highly recommend
watching helix on Syfy okay if you're it
all into that kind of human results all
right well we're not doing helix on Syfy
right now so tell me a little bit more
about sort of what's our van
yes yeah so then so this is the start
and right now I'm trying to infiltrate
myself with this particular group as far
as I can tell there are a couple
factions here and the main enemy is
gonna be it's gonna be the other faction
at this stage in the game I haven't
gotten beyond that like most of my time
has been spent tooling around any
meaningful distinguishing like factors
between these factions or is it like not
like Far Cry where it's like two sides
of the same knot yes again I I've played
five hours but a lot of that has been
tooling around doing stuff and when I
say stuff I mean like literally stuff
I'm just going around and then you get
introduced I don't think we're gonna get
this far in fact I know we won't get
this far but there's a great flowers for
algernon reference Wow okay who would
have thunk it
Oh careful I'll be fine as far as I know
I've never been injured on like barbed
wire how much actual zombie murder is
occurring in this game like you're
already starting about pipes are we in a
situation where guns are already I
haven't gotten any guns yet Wow five
hours in I've yeah I've had some I have
some other stuff I've got some throwing
stars okay and things like that okay
hang on I'm gonna see if I can make this
jump you think I'm probably going to 0
that's fine yeah nailed it just shot a
dragon but that brings up the the hopes
I have skill points first lets us I have
a survivor skill point this stuff kind
of happens automatically as far as I can
tell the more you attack like the more
you get power points and the more
platforming you do the more agility
Elder Scrolls kind of yeah it seems very
much like that and here's your skill
tree for like survival right now I could
only get the survival starter kit but
this helps me learn how to craft
lockpicks firecrackers during stars and
all time well show me the blueprints
what's that a bit so blueprints is where
is like your crafting table okay so this
is where like when I have the stuff that
I need like right now I can make
lockpicks
can you make these wherever you want you
got you can do it wherever you want
great
you don't need crafting tables or
anything like that so you basically have
like a crafting table wherever you
like we're obviously seeing a lot right
now because you say that in the tutorial
but like how much stories happening less
and how much is just killing the five
things and I will say it right so it you
know and in essence it's very much like
that island where it where it's pretty
fetch quest II in a lot of cases but I
like you want me to skip them up so I
have to skip it I have skips every line
firecrackers
that'll they'll they'll come in handy
now he's sending me out to likes rig
some rig some things with traps
oh you have Batman vision okay kind of
so this is called survivor vision okay
so and you can highlight stuff that's in
the environment like this for soon
enough they're just gonna call it a game
vision because every day I have to make
their own concedes as to why they're
able to you should do again is it for
picking up little lighting items yes
it'll highlight things you can interact
with around you not so much for zombies
that'll that that well it does when
nighttime comes it'll become super
helpful I look I like see kind of but
alright okay this is the first time I've
seen this being played in front of me
the same as all the folks who are
watching this at home right now you've
played for five hours right now I'm
thinking this actually looks kind of fun
this looks neat it looks technically
proficient and I can see myself enjoying
exploring and you know messing around
with the multiple systems they're here
how are you finding it five hours in
totally like you you've kind of hit the
nail on the head now it now now I don't
want to be rude or reductive again but I
will say that you know tech land has
that sort of penchant for making janky
things friend I just and this this is
another tech LAN game in that sense in
other words it did make kind of a rough
first impression especially because it's
very cutscene heavy right when it starts
and so you get to see a lot of the
visual
weirdnesses and you know it's it's all I
know I'm running out of stamina so also
she I just wanna point out she also has
no arm what happened in this town but it
you know what it's soup it's it's fun
I'm having fun with it and you know the
first it front loads the things that
aren't so great
the writing is just you know every every
cliche in the book when it comes to
zombie things I always wonder how that
works because this Tecla on the course
are based in Poland so I always wonder
how what do they do they else that was
you did a twofer here every time you hit
them you hit both of them do all right
I'm actually really easy to see what
these guys are like in my plan because
they're so so pulling any stupid
I need useless I'm really fast at night
and they they're so sensitive to sound
at night yeah I mean they're always
sensitive to sound Oh Ed Boon will
happen there well they they sometimes
you stun them and that'll indicate that
you've stun them like I think it's like
a headshot type thing I'll get them in
the head and sometimes they're stunned
by that and you'll you'll see that
particular thing so here's that's pretty
cool so here's the agility tree so now
I'll be able to dodge in combat
important and the power tree what are
skills have you unlocked like on my own
my favorite is still the the the
Dropkick is still my favorite by far
stun is the new one so a chance to blunt
weapons so yeah I think that just
indicates sort of the the head shot that
you get let's go back to the skills like
in my in my main game damn it I'm bad
with controls apparently agility stuff
is my favorite so I also have I skipped
grapple and I got slide which is a
typical thing you can get at this point
where just like you slide yes after you
run so I got its some passive stuff like
health regen I definitely have ball
it's so you can jump over enemies when
you have volts so just run out them in a
volt over comb and yeah and yep there's
my dropkick dropkick so that I love the
dropkick drop take Paco I'm looking
forward to getting dropkick bomb but
that doesn't come until agility level
seven three times more done he's go
right kickin fools and then I went with
free running ad that's the bottom one
what's the bottom one
what's the bottom one ultimate runner
you become the best free runner in the
quarantine you can run jump and climb
without getting tired so
so in that case like you just get
there's no more stamina to worry about
you take that what every other free
runner in the quarantine yeah second
best man while the [ __ ] yeah totally
go in there knocks rude not to
don't mean please we kill the zombies
all right here Oh
sugary for this guy I was great yeah
your tried and tested I take him weather
damn take that dramatic slowdown of him
laying on the ground was very what's
happenin to his innards what's going on
there did you see when you pretty sure
this blood what bloody poop coming out
of his butt you don't get that Zombrex
what did you call it
Anton Anton and twos in but a Z or Zed
UK [ __ ] when you hit him that first time
that was absolutely hilarious
just come pop didn't know how to keep
his balance absorb over Boop oh this is
great how many of these things you need
to arm just to just forget the blue
mouth then no nothing nothing that
dramatic happened all that lady has a
massive hole
her torso walked on board our spine look
at some of these jerks our guy also has
no arm we're done with that what is left
he almost lost her clothes hanging in
there I wasn't her it was another like
these models and this life is richer is
the like the lighting is quite nice does
it operate in real time or is this are
we too early in the game 9 yeah it is
going to as my understanding I'm at the
point where it's you know I just did the
first night mission right well that was
five hours in yeah but again I don't I
think if you're just doing doing story
stuff you know maybe that's an hour in
but me I'm going everywhere I'm because
there's side stuff to do like you pretty
early on you start unlocking side quests
and then I'm going everywhere doing side
quests and then and then I get
distracted doing stuff like this once
you get the drop kick you can like going
around doing this all the time
especially because that you go it's like
playing bowling there's a spot I can't
really get up there now but there's a
spot up on a bridge that's just strewn
with cars and zombies yeah all in a row
you drop kick one it goes flying in
another they just all tumble oh man it's
great I'm sorry no I I forgot I wasn't
on camera like my arms are going
everywhere like I'm trying to explain
this you saw I think so yeah you know
it's got its jank there's a there's a
place coming up I'm not getting anything
more because I know we got to shut down
but they're there there was there's a
place where you have to I know it's
great isn't it I go what you do that all
day it's like knocking over people in
grunt that butterfly it's just a forest
thing look at you lady yeah yeah take
that you dumb piece
this guy he was just telegraphing not
overhead and like up a table leg I
really appreciate have done these
zombies are doing today I was saying
there's no idea what I was saying
because I got so distracted that's good
well I think that'll that'll do I think
this is a good place to just keep being
distracted so I like the Ezio Assassin's
Creed looting that that animation looks
so similar he's roping the zombie it's
pretty much what it looks like it's not
finding anything that's just like you
don't wanna grab a cup a little field
before this is at end of January I think
it's a 27
yeah pretty soon next gen systems over
so Xbox one Playstation 4 and PC the
most next-gen system on the wall Kevin
are thank you so much for your time oh
it's my pleasure Daniel Dwyer